on
bonjour amis internautes
bonjour donc nous sommes ici pour le son
exceptionnelle puisque nous recevons un
invité spécial aujourd'hui
il a été donc vice champion de france en
1993 à nantes il a elle vient de
réaliser
il y a quelques semaines sa deuxième
nombre de grand maître international il
s'agit du maître attention la france est
le plus bronzé du circuit
jean-luc modesto chabanon bonjour jean
luc bonjour et doit alors en quelques
mots on peut présentement un peu ton
style de jeu échiquéen bas on va dire
que mon style est un style quand même
très très agressif c'est un jeu donc je
recherche tout de suite le combat mais
bon en suivant quand même les principes
de base du jeu d'échecs
évidemment les principes élémentaires
c'est à dire que je joue des ouvertures
théorie car en développement mais pièce
mais le plus vite possible je cherche
quand même à avoir des positions très
très compliqué très compliqué donc tu as
un style un peu original un petit peu
hors normes on peut dire en tout cas
c'est la réputation que tu as
est ce que tu peux détailler un peu ce
ce côté de ton ton portrait du joueur
d'échecs bah disons que c'est vrai que
quand on a une longue carrière quand on
joue depuis une dizaine d'années est le
plus intéressant dans ce jeu c'est de
chercher des complications c'est de
faire du spectacle
donc au début je jouais prudemment et
puis bon avec l'expérience et où on peut
se permettre un peu plus de fantaisie
alors ce soir aujourd'hui le spectacle
est au rendez vous puisque jean luc a
choisi une partie assez en harmonie avec
son style donc ça va être très très
intéressant il va nous commenter une
partie kasparov contre wauquiez vix est
maintenant est ce que tu peux nous
expliquer ce choix deux parties puisque
avec toi ce n'est pas une leçon sous
forme de leçon mais plutôt une analyse
de partie bien détaillé alors pourquoi
cette partie 1
mais je pense que cette partie est un
modèle d'attaqué de 2 un exemple pour
pour tout pour tous les téléspectateurs
pour rejouer les positions type de type
sicilienne de défense sicilienne donc en
position ouverte avec une ouverture des
lignes magistral orchestrée par garry
kasparov et donc je pense aussi que l'on
voit quand même une partie donc à sens
unique ce qui est très intéressant
puisque un joueur peut développer
pleinement ses idées et est complètement
dominés et exploiter donc une idée
principale parfait - alors on va voir on
va tout de suite se mettre en
incrustation petit pour commencer cette
cette partie donc nous y voilà voilà
nous sommes au petit avec l'échiquier
qui n'est probablement pas le bon en
fond d'écran mai
il va falloir rectifier ce détail et
ensuite nous pourrons commencer puisque
voilà nous y voilà
alors qu'harry kasparov les blancs ils
jouent eux deux quatre pour toi quels
sont les grands principes de l'ouverture
puisque dans des gones à l' on en a
expliqué certain qu'elles sont à ton
avis les tiens on va bénéficier de ta
présence pour avoir un point de vue
nouveau peut-être sur les ouvertures des
chèques oui donc pour moi évidemment
donc 2 4 et quand le premier coup le
coup le plus le plus agressif qui existe
sur l'échiquier le kop premier coup
puisque après eux de 4 donc les pièces
vont pouvoir se libérer rapidement
c'est-à-dire le fou qui va pouvoir venir
éventuellement en pessac ou en c4 le
cavalier qui peut venir sur la case f3
donc est dans cette position une
ouverture du centre très probable le
plus vite possible
donc contrairement à des deux des cas où
les blancs installe une masse de pions
ils sortent leur pièce avant la les
pièces sont privilégiés dans ce type
d'ouverture
mais quand on privilégie donc la sortie
des pièces c'est une ouverture active et
dynamique
sur quoi alexander wauquiez vix japon
par c'est cette c5 la défense sicilienne
tu affectionnes cette défense c'est une
défense atteint semble je ne joue pas
actuellement cette défense mais je le
regrette je pense que c'est une
ouverture excellente pour pour entrer
dans les complications pour créer
énormément de difficultés à son
adversaire pour une raison principale
c'est que après l'ouverture du centre
par des deux enfin après cavaliers f3 et
par exemple des 6 et des deux des cats
on pourra dire que la structure de pions
sera complètement asymétrique
c'est-à-dire les noirs auront deux pions
à l'est le halal dames contre trois et
cinq pions au centre contre contre 4
donc on peut dire que de ce point de vue
là les plans pourront
donc attaquer attaquer un petit peu mais
bon parce qu'ils sont mieux développer
mais les noirs ont la manière de réagir
puisqu'ils peuvent très facilement
contrôlé le centre par 6 des sacs
oui alors effectivement ici ce qu'on
peut dire c'est que les les blancs donc
enfin les noirs contrôle le centre avec
l'option en c5
ce n'est pas symétrique comparé par
enfin par opposition à eux 7 5 ont
veillé le coup qu'on joue et il y a
longtemps
donc c'est cette c5 entraîne évidemment
des complications plus plus importante
et à leur rappel quand même des trois
principes de l'ouverture qu'on a dit
dans diagonale c1 il faut sortir ces
pièces de il faut contre les centres et
3 une forte rapidement et ici donc
kasparov joue deux cavaliers f3 un coup
très logique ou et le coup dorval oui
donc normal 17 des six est maintenant
des deux décades bon je pense que on va
pas s'attarder trop non plus sur ce coup
là c'est très logique quand on installe
un duo tour centrale kazakhe exactement
il faut occuper le centre donc les
blancs pouces immédiatement le plan tu
es tu en prends des quatre là on reprend
bien entendu du cavalier et pas de la
dame
on peut reprendre de la dame mais la
reprise du cavalier est quand même plus
naturel si on reprend de la dame les
noirs peuvent jouer cavalier b8 c6
attaqué la dame et pour ne pas perdre de
temps les blancs se retrouveraient forcé
de jouer le couffo f1 bessac qui n'est
pas forcément mauvais mais qui il est
qui qui enlève toute souplesse à la
position enfin en gros pour résumer la
situation
quand on prend avec la dame on va sortir
notre dame trop tôt elle va être
susceptible d'être attaqué et ça va
causer des embêtements provenant des
pertes de temps côté blanc donc méfiance
donc méfiance cavani prend des quatre
très logique
canal et m6 qui avait laissé croire les
blancs sortent bien toutes leurs pièces
nos deux pièces près du centre les noirs
- cavaliers qui contrôle un petit peu et
ici le cou à cette assise donc la
défense
nash dehors la défense nage dorff donc
la défense la plus populaire dans le
monde des échecs avec la défense est
indienne donc c'est une défense qui est
la défense favorite de garry kasparov
donc garé qui a les blancs là dans cette
position est vraiment sur son terrain de
prédilection donc à 6 un coût qui est
finalement qui est très logique puisque
bon les noirs vont hésiter entre la
poussée du point e en os 6 où la poussée
du point e en août 5 et donc dans cette
position il décide de jouer un coût qui
n'est pas vraiment un coup
prophylactique qui permettra
éventuellement la contre attaque par
bessette bessac donc la contre attaque
et se couper cette baie 5 éventuellement
qui si on joue parlant b5 bi 4 permet de
d'attaquer le centre donc c'est un coup
très utile par rapport au centre très
utile mais quand même on a envie de dire
dans l'ouverture il faut sortir ces
pièces pourquoi je mets un coup de pied
comme ça qui ne contrôle pas le centre
qui ne soit pas de pièce et qui n'aide
pas invoqué est ce qu'on peut se
permettre de jouer ça avec les noirs on
peut se permettre dans cette position là
en général je déconseille ce genre de
coup là ça on peut dire c'est la
position parfaite pour jouer cette
ouverture mais en général évidemment le
cou à cette a6 ou le courage 7h hills
n'a aucun sens voilà les fameuses
oreilles d'âne si vous connaissez un peu
cette expression c'est les coûts à 7 à
6h 7h hills et à 3h 3 pour les blancs
foutoir et kasparov
logique donc garry kasparov l'acquis qui
est très très directe qui développe ses
pièces donc éventuellement avec l'idée
de jouer d'amd de grand roque donc
arriver tout de suite à l'essentiel
c'est à dire la tacc et après pousser
ses pions à les droits pour pour manger
le roi noir
alors une question il faut choisir un
côté pour ok pourquoi est-ce que garry
kasparov va choisir de faire le grand
roque au lieu du petit rock qui est plus
naturelle dans cette position que garry
kasparov préfère
jouer grand vote puisqu'il veut utiliser
finalement ça paris iv de pions cette
majorité de pions allen dame donc les
pions à deux baies de ces deux pour
protéger son roi et finalement comme il
est en infériorité de l'autre côté
autant pousser ses pions et ouvrir les
lignes puisque de toute façon il pourra
pas lancer une attaque avec le petit
rock d'accord donc est ce qu'on peut
dire en comme une règle comme un
principe en tout cas quand on a moins de
pions d'un côté l'échiquier c'est
intéressant de les pousser pour faire ce
qu'on appelle une attaque de minorité
c'était une attaque ans avec moins de
moins de matériel oui je pense que le
roi doit toujours choisir le côté où il
ya le plus de pions d'accord donc ici
choix très logique de garry kasparov qui
joue faux et 3 pour finalement essayé de
jouer avec le grand roque
bon de toute façon ici il développe ses
pièces en plus haut cet os 6 donc là on
a à nouveau transposer dans un autre
petit système je crois je crois que là
on est dans une riche teurs pas encore
on est encore dans une âge d'or nous
sommes encore de neige d'or servent
encore douzaine d'acheteurs tout à fait
donc de 7,6 à coup développement qui
contrôle le centre qui contrôle la casse
des sacs très important donc le sens
très très bien contrôlé la casse des
sables la case 5 et la case c5 dont
l'idée de ce coup aussi ses preuves ou
des fossettes et petit recul pour il
peut être qu'on peut
on peut dire ça a un coût de
développement est également aussi un
coût de développement sachant que le fou
s'est vite on le sortira plus on g4
malheureusement mais on ne mettra plus
doyen oui et on privilégie donc à la
sortie du fou l'acompte le contrôle de
la case des soins
oui contre la caste des cinq casques les
dans la cécilienne effectivement c'est
le fameux coup libérateur des six des
cinq qu'on a toujours envie de jouer et
ici donc que 7,6 très naturelle dans
l'optique de finalement un jour pouvoir
jouer des six des cinq f2 f3 donc f2 f3
donc là on prépare donc sept petites
barricades donc on prépare dam des deux
pour on évite le coup peut-être
cavaliers f6 gkp qui pour être
désagréable on contrôle la casse jca t
on prépare donc dam des deux est grand
roque
voilà tout à fait l'explication de ce
coin f3 est simple on contrôle la case
g4 c'est la casse qui est ici pour
empêcher que qu'elles viennent s'y
mettre et ensuite peut-être dans un
deuxième temps je mangeais de g4 et
commencer cette marée d'options cette
marée de pions que l'on aptel que l'on
appelle l' attaque à la baïonnette
c'est une
c'est une expression que l'on emploie
lorsqu'un adversaire donc sur une aile
sur l'ale où il a l'intention d'attaquer
pousse tous ses pions traître est
sauvagement il épouse de deux cases tout
de suite et ils les avances brutalement
les fantassins donc armés de leurs
baïonnettes c'est exact cette image là
exactement bessette b5 g2g 4 août par
garry kasparov
là je crois que les subtilités dans
l'ouverture c'est que l'on veut pas
laisser une pièce noire allait en 17
mais je ne
peut-être tu joues bien cette ouverture
je crois je m'en souviens plus très bien
je crois qu'on l'avait expliqué dent
dans l'émission anglaise avec malcom on
avait expliqué les petites subtilités
dans cette position donc garry kasparov
qui a préjugé de g4 a introduit je crois
je sais plus si c'est à ce moment là le
coup cavaliers hexis 17 cavaliers p 6
mai donc ça c'est des grandes
spécialités on va pas trop s'attarder
là-dessus g2g cas de toute façon le
début de l'attaqué baïonnette donc à
coup tout à fait naturel g4 l'idée est
bien entendu du g5 alors garry kasparov
délaisse un peu le grand qu on peut dire
ça puisque pour l'instant il n'a rien
fait dans ce sens il vient de jouer
franc jeu les quatre alors est-ce que ça
pose un problème normalement il faut pas
faire ça je pense ça peut poser un
problème si les noirs sont bien
développées actuellement les noirs ont
développé très peu de pièces dans le
gabarit et kasparov anticipe sylvaner
sorte une pièce il sort sa dame si les
noirs sorte une autre pièce l'aï rock
oui c'est effectivement c'est un très
bon indicateur pour le dans la position
ici on voit que les blancs ont sorti
trois pièces et les noirs une seule donc
a priori pas trop de risques pour les
blancs de se faire exploser dans cette
position exactement les dogues
exactement donc les les blancs qui
sentent le bon timing
ils peuvent se permettre de jouer un
petit peu olé olé avec le roi au centre
g4 cavalli b17 d'amendé deux dames dès 2
h 7 h 6
c'est empêche j'ai capté 5 je crois dans
calories h6 pour éviter g4 g5 elle se
retrouvait donc un petit peu on dire un
petit peu à l'étroit avec ses deux
cavaliers donc évidemment l'autre
solution aurait été de jouer cavalier 17
b6 donc toujours dans le souci de faire
respirer un petit peu les pièces de les
faire bouger donc ça aurait permis sur
la poussée g4 g5 de jouer cavalier f 6
oui mais là on dit aussi on est quand
même dans les ouvertures qu'il faut pas
à rejoindre deux fois avec la même pièce
si on joue et kelly b 6 après j'ai cinq
cahiers f17 ça jouer les cavaliers
quatre fois c'était pas c'est pas une
bonne opération
oui donc h 7 h 6 pour éviter aussi que
les blancs prennent de l'espace à quoi
porte en elle c'est à ce niveau là pour
garder le contrôle direct les spurs
jouent gros rock voilà donc il a fini
par faire rock et les noirs ont fini par
se développer presque totalement mais
pas complètement fou 17 alors là on peut
compter les temps les blancs en sortie 5
pièces on peut dire ça si on compte 1 il
ya deux cavaliers un fou la dame et le
roi qui a troqué sa fait cinq pièces les
noirs eux n'en n'ont sorti que trois et
c'est encore aux blancs de jouer en
revanche ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
les noirs sont prêts à jouer le coup
libérateur c'était rb5 b4 chasser le
cavalier et ensuite des six des 5 alors
ça c'est effectivement ça c'est une
remarque qui s'adresse principalement
aux experts ce fameux coup des six des
cinq dans la cécilienne mais ici les
noirs sont prêts à jouer ça est en tout
cas ce qu'on peut dire aussi c'est que
kasparov est un grand habitué de cette
position mais ne casse pas en fait un
grand habitué de cette position
puisqu'ils gagnent régulièrement des
parties avec les blancs ils gagnent
régulièrement des parties avec les noirs
c'est le grand spécialiste c'est le
numéro mondial de cette position ca c
probablement le joueur qui connaît sa
position depuis depuis depuis une
vingtaine d'années déjà puisqu'il a déjà
joué la défense sicilienne en 84 ou 85
contre anatoli karpov dans son son
premier match il avait commencé par la
défense sicilienne il avait même
introduit des coûts nouveaux et des
idées très intéressantes
et donc voilà donc dans cette position
on peut dire que kasparov et il le
maître absolu
le maître absolu tout simplement en un
mot c'est le maître absolu et il connaît
très bien cette position
il connaît donc toute la subtilité il
joue le coup 11 h 4 il continue cette
attaque est la baïonnette en là c'est
très logique en fait ce qui se passe
c'est que les blancs poussent leurs
pions
oui donc là de toute façon les blancs
n'ont plus rien à perdre ils ont mis le
roi l'abri aal.l dames et donc il décide
tout simplement de jouer hk tg4 et de
continuer g4 g5 et donc de continuer et
d'ouvrir peut-être plus tard par g6
peut-être de fragiliser donc le luron
l'instant je t'arrête puisque sur g5 il
y aurait comme un pion pranger 5e pour
l'instant ce n'est pas possible c'est
enfin c'est possible mais on serait
obligé de reprendre du fou de reprendre
du fouillis puisque si on reprend du
pillon du pion h
la tourache fuite viendrait prendre la
tourache 1 donc on sera obligé de
reprendre g5 du fou effectivement enfin
en envisageant en supposant que ce soit
encore obligé une deuxième fois il
jouerait g5 les noirs prendre et on sera
obligé de prendre du fou et ça on n'a
pas envie parce que ça casserait un peu
notre structure d'attac exactement
aurait donc ici pour l'instant il va
falloir dans un premier temps défendre
cette tour à chaud pour pouvoir jouer g5
et reprendre du courage et ensuite
effectivement peut-être ton plan jouer
g5 un g6
oui je pense qu'on peut résumer la
position comme ça mais bon c'est au nord
de jouer comme ici et pour l'instant les
blancs n'ont pas de menace directe on
peut dire ça puisqu'on est adjugé 5 donc
les noirs ont le temps de faire quelque
chose il joue b4 donc bekkat la réaction
dont on avait parlé donc la réaction
centrale pourrait les les noirs vont
également essayé de faire parler leurs
rollers fou de cases blanches le fou
bessette donc
en jouant bekkat après les locales les
vies dans lequel vient à 4 hélas les
noirs jouent des cinq donc le fou 17 qui
exercent une pression sur le pion e cat
et qui demande cacau carte à jouer donc
dans cette position il est noir ont
envie de prendre le pur au caté de jouer
d'ouvrir les lignes alors ici cependant
un peu paradoxal puisque les bleus ont
quand même développé plus de pièces ils
ont rauque et ils ont déjà sorti trois
pièces mineurs et c'est les noirs qui
ouvre la position alors est ce qu'on dit
papin dans les ouvertures
il ne faut pas ouvrir la pression tant
qu'on n'a pas terminé notre
développement est ici pour le cas c'est
absolument pour les noirs c'est
absolument pas le cas puisqu'ils ont
comme le roi au centre exactement on
peut dire que ce genre de choix est
quand même assez optimiste on peut dire
que les noirs sous-estiment les les
forces les forces en action dans le camp
des blancs et ils vont très rapidement
se retrouver en grande difficulté il
faut aussi rappeler aussi donc que cette
ouverture a un nom cette position exacte
donc c'est une attaque à la baïonnette
de la défense nash dehors de la
cécilienne donc beaucoup de nos échecs
et donc aussi on appelle aussi sale
attaque anglaise donc cette façon
d'attaquer avec l'efs 3g cat une attaque
anglaise donc aucune nomenclature digne
des plus grands chimistes exactement
donc voilà donc très bien donc décédé
six des cinq donc la fameuse
quand tu disais décidé ça que la fameuse
c'est le goût de le nom de l'ouverture
juste pour récapituler c'est l'attaquant
gleizes dans le bagne honnête dans la
sicile oui on peut dire exactement
d'accord donc décider si deux des cinq
très très logique en tout cas puisque
les blancs ne peuvent pas jouer g4 g5 ce
n'est toujours pas leur s'ils prennent
en d5 les noirs vont reprendre du
cavalier et vont commencer à gagner
beaucoup de temps puisqu'ils vont
attaquer le fou ils auront plus trop de
problèmes une fois que le cabinet plus
au wef 6 les blancs au moins d'objectifs
d'attac donc ici salaires en fait assez
logique finalement pour les noirs cette
position il va ça va forcer les blancs
en fait à faire une réaction qui n'est
pas habituel puisque par exemple s'ils
jouent aux quatre simples pions est en
prison il ya le khalife 17
s'ils prennent un dessin qu'on a vu que
c'était pas très bon et ils ne peuvent
pas défendre l'option os 4 qui a attaqué
trois fois attaqué par le fou par le
cavalier et par l'option donc ici
apparemment il n'y a pas de solution
pour les blancs oui il n'y a pas de
solution mais il ya quand même un
développement chez les blancs qui est
quand même assez impressionnant donc les
blancs continuent leur développement
parfois h3 et là ils ont une cible
ils ont une cible très très déjà ils
permettent la poussée du congé dans un
premier temps c'est à dire après j'ai 5
h projet saclay blanc peuvent reprendre
du pian h puisque la tourache un des
plus en prise tout à fait puisque le fou
s'est interposé dans un deuxième temps
il attaque le pion aux six dons qu'ils
attaquent le plus réussi avec leur foi
tshz3 lecavalier des cats et se plonger
5 peut casser cette structure de pion
par g5 un g6 donc fragilisé la structure
de pions et permettent la prise du plan
réussisse et l'ouverture totale du du
camp des blancs et donc les blancs sont
prêts à aider du camp des noirs et donc
les blancs sont prêts à faire ceci pour
pour un pur pour le pur 4 oui donc ici
les noirs
ne prennent pas le pion il aurait pu
prendre il aurait pu jouer des cinq
promotions de 4 avec des complications
avec des grosses complications après g5
ils n'ont pas voulu ils ont préféré
jouer autre chose mais ils ont joué g7
gesac donc donc l'idée évidemment si on
a bien compris c'est une idée c'est
d'éviter la poussée de ce puits angers 4
et de retarder un petit peu l'ouverture
des lignes mais quand même comme on l'a
constaté tout à l'heure un manque
d'harmonie quand même chez les noirs une
ouverture quand même
probablement pas très correct et là que
va trouver gary alors ce coût a quand
même à un gros défaut positionnelle si
je puis dire c'est quand même enfin aux
échecs normalement on a un plan de jeu
c'est à dire qu'on a envie de mettre
l'europe à l'abri quelque part ici pour
clairement pour les noirs c'était de
faire le petit rock après ce coup g7 g5
faire le petit rock avec des pions
avancer comme ça ça paraît un peu
délicat et faire le grand hotel paris
aussi puisque l'option b 4 a été
vraiment trop avancé donc ici qu'est ce
que les noirs espère dans cette position
puisqu'ils n'ont plus aucune perspective
de protéger le roi un jour les noirs aux
espère tout simplement bien bloqué la
tacc mai mais de toute façon leur la
défense noire n'est pas vraiment bien
fondé je pense que les noirs ont une
position vraiment catastrophique où
d'accord donc ici déjà un drame pour
votre chien x qui souffre contre garry
kasparov le roi de la neige d'or
pourtant votre qui vix s'étaient
qualifiés donc pour ce tournoi et donc
ils s'étaient qualifiés sur internet en
battant les meilleurs joueurs de la
planète
oui mais on y est enfin cela n'entre pas
spécialement dans le cadre d'une leçon
d'échec
j'en prends g5 comprend g5 le coût de
4,5 à la csu perhaps coup non oui e45
donc là la démonstration donc totale de
l' avantage positionnelle des blancs
puisque la après e45 on va dire que par
en sacrifiant ce pion les blancs dans un
premier temps en ferme définitivement le
foot baisse est donc le plus inquiétant
crise effectivement le fourbe et 7
maintenant nous sortira plus on voit là
puisque l'option des cinq ne peut plus
bouger et ils ouvrent les lignes donc
les lignes la colonne des et la colonne
eu donc les lignes directes qui sont
face au roi noir
donc voilà face au roi et à la dame
noire donc voilà sept de ligne donc et
après ils vont ils vont pouvoir très
rapidement attaqué ce cavalier e 5,6 ce
qu'on en fait le mois on va commencer
par faire c'est jouer cavalier prono 5
qui est un coup forcé pour les noirs les
noirs ici sont obligés de prendre ce
pion exacte a vraiment le choix et garry
kasparov maintenant je vous fous projet
alors ici il ya une égalité matérielle
oui chaque joueur à cinq pions et toutes
les pièces à égalité matérielle sauf que
les blancs ont imposé un clouage sur le
cabinet sis quand tu vois j'ai assez
désagréable maintenant ils vont
effectivement mettre leur tour ici ça va
être très fort donc ici net avantage
pour gary kasparov je pense qu'on peut
problème le dire déjà tout à fait de
toute façon les blancs sens mieux depuis
depuis quelques coups depuis quelques
coups tour g8 bon développement peut on
peut attribuer excès du développement on
ne pourra plus jouer le petit autant
bouger la tour oui éventuellement
quelques idées caché puisque il ya la
tacc du fou donc éventuellement quelques
possibilités pour pour un petit peu par
exemple éventuellement tenter une astuce
comme cavalier au cas tout pour essayer
de simplifier la position posséder
changer les dames encore dire que dans
cette fois sur les noirs mon objectif
c'est d'échanger les nomme exactement
une fois qu'elles seront changés il ya
beaucoup moins de perspectives d'
attaque
exactement hélas garry kasparov et une
petite combinaison ajout cavaliers à 4
ans b6 inattendu un coup de massue on
pourrait même appeler ça puisque c'est
un cookie qui vient de nulle part le
cavalier est en prise alors à noter que
c'était comme la seule pièce de garry
kasparov qui n'était pas très active
avec le foie je crois en fait il ya deux
pièces pas très active est ici par son
dernier coup donc revoyons images au
ralenti
le coc cavaliers à 4 qu'il advient en b
6 ça va replacer la seule pièce blanche
qui n'était pas spécialement dans
l'action exactement et qui revient vers
énormément de cases c'est à dire tout
cas toutes les cases blanches qui sont
dans le dans le camp des dans le camp
des noirs c'est à dire la case d7 d5 et
tout ça donc l'aller
le cavalier blanc qui fait des ravages
donc dans le camp des noirs de gros
ravages tout à fait appel et 6 4 pour
échanger lecavalier l'aca de la partie
pour le tout tactique quand même très
très tactique
cependant on oublie de signaler que sur
dame prend b6 le fou peut détrôner
enlève si c'est que la position de noir
étaient de plus en plus difficile
juste après fou prend m6 le plonger
pourrait avancer angers ça qui est le
faux h3 lecavalier des cats et latour
éventuellement qui viendrait sur roja
pourrait complètement miné le plan du 6
au 8 août la pièce blanche serait placé
au mieux le camillo 5 seraient délogés
ça serait une tout simplement une
catastrophe donc sur cavani ces quatre
cavaliers français 4 puis en france et 4
ici le fou mais cette revient dans la
partie
mais gary je crois qu'il il a vu que
loin dans sept pays qui on l a vu
beaucoup plus loin puisqu'il a vu la
combinaison gagnante
à partir de cette position là c'est
superbe on voyait exactement et la dent
gary qui qui ne laisse aucune chance à
son adversaire et qui termine qui
termine la partie donc par par une
combinaison magistrale dont enzo
magistral alors qu'est-ce que
qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce qui peut
donner l'idée de faire une combinaison
dans cette position et comment de gary a
trouvé bon peut-être trouvé la montre
est d'abord oui mais ce qui peut faire
les huskies qui peut donner l'idée de
faire une combinaison dans cette
position c'est tout simplement que les
blancs en développer toutes leurs pièces
que toutes leurs pièces sont en action
on toutes les pièces blanches attaques
des points sensibles donc le fou j'ai
cinq clous cavaliers le cas meilleur des
cas tu attaques le plan réussisse le
fond h trois galettes éventuellement sur
le pion aux 6 les tours sont prêtes à
entrer en action sur l'école ouverte qui
sont eux et d en face du roi et en face
on a appauvri roi qui est qui et là tout
seul et tout et forcément je veux dire
c'est des conditions il est parfaite
pour pour terminer la partie donc
effectivement si on compte les pièces
développées pour les noirs n'y en a que
deux pour les blancs il y en a quatre
ça fait un énorme avantage de
développement il faut trouver quelque
chose donc garry kasparov ici à trouver
il échoue pointe 6 la dame vient prendre
le fou et maintenant la combinaison
proprement dite c'est le coup cavaliers
des 4 prend pion aux six ce coup là oui
al avec donc une menace déjà direct
d'échec et mat dame 17 qui serait donc
échec et mat alors deux possibilités
pour les noirs il faut prendre ce
cavalier il est deux fois en prise n'est
pas défendu il va falloir le prendre on
peut le prendre de la dame ou du pion
alors ok vix a pris du plomb je veux
qu'il n'a pas pris au québec ce n'est
pas prêt il a joué franchissent les jeux
fasciste et n'a pas pris oui alors il
avait donc une troisième possibilité oui
puisque s'il prend du plomb il ya échec
et mat
c'est tout à fait tout à fait correct
ici il y aurait d'amd cet échec et mat 1
donc tout à fait un peu peur du pion vos
keryx n'a pas pris parce que s'il prend
de la dengue il a également un autre
problème sur le thème du cloud âge
exactement dans tour h 1 e 1 et la dame
est perdu la dame est perdue puisque
cloud et cloud et elle ne peut pas
bouger il ya le roi derrière donc là je
vous invite à revenir sur la leçon
portant le thème du cloud âge pour en
savoir plus sur ce thème en tout cas ici
ça perdrait tout simplement la dame
et ce n'est pas une option contre garry
kasparov donc revoyons encore ce qu'il
s'est passé
nouveau xive x doit trouver un autre
coup puisque qu'elle prend 1,6 à gagner
un pion et tu le couffo h 10
avec ploie jossie exactement la dame des
deux est cloué la dame des deux est
cloué elle ne peut pas bouger puisque le
roi est derrière donc il faut trouver
une solution sinon on va perdre la dame
oui mais il ya une solution dans cette
position les gars il a trouvé
oui il joue g4 g5 tout simplement donc
le pion gesac étant défendue par le
cavalier en u6 et donc la galerie n'est
pas très inquiète donc si le fou pranger
5e le cavalier peut prendre le fou il ne
perd pas la dame et il continue son
attaque sur le roi noir oui y voyons
quand même que dans l'air se trouve le
coutour h sur un échec
donc c'est très dur pion prend 2,6 si on
prend la dame
wauquiez vix arrivera enfin à ce qu'il a
toujours voulu faire c'est à dire une
finale une finale et finale megrahi
évidemment ne veut pas de cette finale
il joue d'amd cet échec l'a forcé à
venir ou alors c'est le droit de suite
et maintenant on ne peut toujours pas
reprendre la dame puisque l'option est
cloué on y sert que si l'option pour la
dame
le roi se retrouve aux prises ce délai
la possible ce qui est interdit
nous comprend le fou exactement c'est en
droit on attaque au passage l'autre fou
et le plan réussisse et le pion aux six
en actions h qui est à 2 càs de dan qui
on achète très vite très proches de la
dame en à roy noir qui est complètement
dépouillé enfants noirs et dépouillé
donc ici en fait on peut dire que les
blancs sont ont suffisamment davantage
pour être gagnant on peut on peut dire
que les blancs aignan à cause de tous
ces petits avantages sur ses petits
facteurs on va voir comment gagner
conclut cette partie après fou des 5
il joue dam des six échecs tout
simplement une plus besoin de jouer des
choses très très compliqué donc injecté
pour replacer la dame peut être zappé
roll donc d'un mais cette hausse est
d'un f4 nouvel échec damev cette dame
sac et maintenant dames 5 et l'a évoqué
vix abandonne oui alors on a envie de
dire pourquoi donc maintenant dans cette
position où gary a donc à jeter toutes
ses cartouches offensives
donc on peut dire que tout simplement
donc vu qu'avis abandonnent parce que le
pion à celle de casse de dames
il suffit tout simplement de bouger le
foot cases blanches le foie jeu 3 pour
soutenir ce pur h avec la tourache a
donc déjà ça c'est un premier point le
avantages matériels et blanc les blancs
au tapis en plus et la tour des uns peut
éventuellement être transférées en des
cats pour vous piquer la dame en f4 pour
clouer la dame donc le roi noir est
complètement dépouillé comme je l'aï dit
auparavant
donc autant de raisons qui font que
quand on se retrouve face au numéro un
mondial quand on n'est pas complètement
développé et quand on est quand on
allumait talent moi et quand on a du mal
et quand on est très très mal aux sons
des res et des raisons très importante
pour abandonner de toute façon dans
cette position il n'a aucune chance
alors jean luc maintenant en quelques
mots est ce que tu peux nous résumer ce
qui s'est passé dans cette partie et
pourquoi gary kasparov a gagné est un
peu pourquoi tout simplement
donc ce qui sait ce qui peut être
expliquée dans sa partie cycle donc de
garry kasparov donc à développer ces
pièces naturellement il a joué donc une
défense et ciel mon l'ouverture les
cinq-six premiers coups étaient
peut-être correct mais très vite les
noirs ont joué le coup h si ce qui a
permis au blanc de gagner des temps de
développement et comme c'est une
position ouverte le développement a été
très important et il à l'ouverture des
lignes chez les blancs a été fantastique
donc on peut dire que garry kasparov à
part des petites combinaisons a augmenté
son avantage et a finalement
conclut donc une très belle partie d'
attaques de garry kasparov qui a su bien
managé la coordination de toutes ces
pièces bien bien revenir bien attaquer
en tout cas donc c'était une belle
partie de gary cette leçon va se
terminer
donc jean luc chavanon merci d'être
venus merci je pense qu'on va se
retrouver la semaine prochaine
oui je crois que l'on va pour une
émission en anglais l'émission en
anglais et une nouvelle leçon donc amis
internautes merci de nous avoir suivi et
à la semaine prochaine